have you have you like because I don't
go on Tick Tock how is this far anyway
I'm actually going for a jacket off
because I got okay I don't go into that
but I have I've I've seen this happen to
other people where
um they've like they've had something on
their Tick Tock which has popped up that
has been relevant to like some very
specific intrusive thought that they've
never like verbalized or anything like
that but Tick Tock is just like oh
here's a video about that one topic that
you've thought about that's coincidence
and then when you spot it it feels so
much more real than you know just yeah
it's a mixture of coincidence and the
fact that I think there are so many Tech
talks out there now that have just
covered every possible internal like
situation that could be relevant to you
okay I want an AI that tells you what my
next dark thought is gonna be
it's like an AI that like warns you
before you have the thought it's just
like stop right now you're just chilling
and you have that one thought you're
like whoa that was dark
you know you're okay come on I cannot be
alone in this you know that's just like
every year you see that on a tick tock
that's [__] up well that's cool that's
sick no because like because this has
happened to like Sydney a few times uh
where she's just like Cindy likes to
bring up random stuff sometimes and uh
if you hang out with Sydney she she says
the dog says out loud every [__]
intrusive and non-intrusive thought
whether they make sense or not yeah so
one time she was uh we're just like
[__] watching TV or something and
then she just goes to me could you
survive a tsunami if you like are in a
swimming pool and you switch to the
bottom of the swimming pool and hold
your breath
should I be offended
and he was one of those statements
at the bottom just swim in the bottom of
the way it'll just go right right just
swim to the bottom and it was like one
other it was
and it was one of those moments where I
heard a statement and I didn't even know
where to begin because I'm just I'm just
like I don't think this is even worth
entertaining the thought I'm just like I
just like what and she's like no I I
think like has anyone ever thought about
that I'm like
Sydney
and I just left that was that you know
that was like I was like I did not know
where to begin and I was just like John
left he went to his computer and you
started programming in AI
[__] you're not right [__] you're not
yeah and then like two days later
um I was I was like she's lying in bed
and she go and she goes what the [__] no
way and I was like Sydney what's going
on
and she she runs down to me and she goes
watch this Tick Tock and a tick tock is
here's why you wouldn't survive if you
swam to a bottom of a pool during a
tsunami and I was just like I thought
that that is that is the creepiest [__]
I've ever seen in my life and I don't
know if this was like a subconscious
Trend that was happening during Tick
Tock but I have never heard anyone pose
this question before I just like to
think just out of context that Tick Tock
was just one that Sydney made like that
night
Target it's just like check it out I'm
not the only one that's thinking this
I'm not weird right
please believe me yeah
I don't know because I don't know if
you've driven my when you do you only
drive a lot and you've driven a lot of
hours and then you sit there and you
have that moment where you're like
oh yeah if I [__] this up I die
yeah I've had that you know when you're
just you just drive it like you're like
you're like oh this is super chill this
is funny you do it every day and then
you're just like oh wait I gotta I gotta
pay attention
not that I'm not paying attention yeah
but you know when you just and no one's
ever gonna want to get him to call me
ever again no but you know what I mean
like you're just driving and then you
forget how dangerous driving is until
you have that moment where you're like
oh if I just turn if I accidentally
wasn't paying attention I turned a
little bit that way I it would it's over
it's it's that moment [__] up why do I
have those thoughts it's a [__] up uh
I guess I guess all of the time I saw
this tweet yeah it was this woman and it
was a woman standing like lying on the
edge of a waterfall yeah she was just
kind of like oh I think I see that
someone retreated it and it was
something like nah the voices would get
me for sure
and they had like 300 000 likes but you
know I was like the voices
I'm a safe driver guys I'm a safe
guys
we've had a road trip together they're
in one piece okay yeah so sometimes
you're on a highway right
you see like oncoming traffic right and
you're going like 70 miles per hour and
you're and sometimes you get this
thought sometimes do you ever look at
this
like everyone's life is in my hands
right now oh yeah no no no I know I know
it's like if I if I don't know
all I have to do is just turn the
steering wheel slightly and everyone's
dead good thing I'm not gonna do that
but what if
oh good thing I'm not gonna do okay but
good thing I'm a sane human being what
if or am I or am I
who actively has that thought everyone
collectively is driving and everyone
doesn't not drive safe when they do yeah
exactly I know it's also like when
driving sometimes you especially in Long
stretches it's I think intrusive
thoughts is different from just being in
kind of like getting into like this
almost vegetative state where you're
just so focused on the road that you
forget that you're going at like 70
miles that's a phenomenon right where
you know some people if they drive back
to work all the time and it's a
relatively short distance some people
can forget that they even drove to work
that like they don't have the memory of
driving the car because they've done it
so many times and it's so automatic yes
it all just Blends together
have you ever had a autopilot moment in
your life where you just like for sure
you wake up you wake up from the Matrix
and you're like why did I do this I well
like you're just walking and you
suddenly forget like you're walking you
just you don't like you don't you don't
like have that thought that you're
actually controlling your walking
no there's the moment that I'm sure
everyone in the world has experience at
least once of like you're just you know
you're in the living room and then you
walk to your room and then you enter
your room and then you just stop and you
go why did I just walk away of course of
course
everyone's had that that is that is like
an autopilot moment my my brain just
pre-programmed to be like walk to yours
because like I'll never forget that
that's like that that's like every day
of my life
Welcome to ADHD everyone but like I
remember like the worst time it happened
and the part that still like freaks me
out is I remember
I remember this one time
um in University
um so you know you go to your lecture or
every single day of your [__] life
right
and then I remember leaving my house
because it was the weekend yeah and then
ladies and gentlemen it was the weekend
and I was going to meet a few friends in
the city center
um so I started walking I put on my
earphones uh and then the next thing I
realized I look up and I'm in front of
my lecture hall and I'm like why the
[__] did I go here how did I walk it was
it was the autopilot walk today
autopilot walked to the leg Hall and
it's not a short walk it was a 30-minute
walk what I did not notice that I was
walking to my lecture hall which is the
opposite direction to where I was going
to meet my mates until I was in front of
the lecture hall dude if that isn't
solid evidence that like fast travel
exists in real life like I don't know
what it is
you just press the button and you just
you just fast travel to the election my
horse traveled to the wrong place I'm
like I glitched down oh wait wait I
don't I don't actually need to go yeah
yeah that is evidence like because I'm
sure everyone has experienced that I'm
just like oh I'm here now but I don't
remember how I got here yeah I just I
just like oh I just my my feet just
started walking and I'm here now okay
that's just the pre-programmed script
just started right it's just like all
right here we go bro that's so fun
that's every time I walk back I feel
like a night of drinking sometimes
holy [__] I've had like insanely song
water insanely long walks after I'm like
[__] pissed out of my mind yeah I
have no idea how I like get back because
I could barely like form two I could
barely form like a single step and I'm
like so I wake up next day and I
perfectly am always home and I always
remember getting I remember I always
remember going into my door and getting
back in but I can never remember the
journey that took me there telling you
man fast travel
it's IRL fast IRL fast travel it exists